you're photogenic baby Isaac very
photogenic baby what happened what
happened I got older I got pretty good
morning guys coffee's done it is Sunday
morning we just woke up it is 10:30 my
plan was to wake up like at 6:00 a.m.
and then take like a good hour to get
ready and then tackle today's task we
totally did it
yeah we totally did it because you got
home really late last night and then I
want to say pretty late so yeah we
didn't end up doing that right yeah
really nice so I looked through the
thing cuz I wanted to make hair drader
yeah and when I'm ready and then I
thought oh yeah what are you gonna use
that for your omelet
you look so cute in your row making your
own breakfast
you big 12 year old you careful with
those sleeves that could be a dangerous
we are tackling a pretty big test today
the plan is this is how I do my coffee
by the way I gotta mix it I first like
foam up the creamer with this creamer
foamer and then I use it against like
mix it the plan is to purge out
everything we don't want in this house
[Music]
it's like doing the Marie Kondo stuff
where it's like does this spark joy no
then toss it or actually thank you and
then toss it
but first we need to get rid of a huge
pile of cardboard trash that we've had
since we moved into this house and which
is four years ago almost five years ago
that's something major and we need to
get rid of that pile so then that whole
space in the garage can be used for all
the things that we want to sell and get
rid of because tomorrow
my theater Mona she's coming over she
literally has made a living off of
selling things that like swap meets like
or another word for slot means those
flea markets so doing that or doing like
garage sales or yard sales or all that
stuff so she's a pro at like selling
things because in a couple weeks we will
be moving so I'm trying to like yeah I'm
trying to purge every single thing that
we don't want to take to the house this
storage space that I'm talking about
right now that we currently have in our
garage we don't have that that amount of
space in the new house so we really need
to shed everything that we don't want a
lot of things that we currently have
right now I feel I feel are like my
early 20s kind of stuff a whole bunch of
Ikea stuff like things that are like
barely hanging hanging on and they are
about to break let's buy some grown-up
stuff finally and luckily not so long
ago I feel like it's been a year already
since
did the konmari thing to our closets but
we're just gonna do it do it another
sweep see what else we can get rid of
that looks really really good made
really good making eggs sunny-side up
mm-hmm you had years of experience huh
who talked to how to do that that guy
over there you taught him how to make
these delicious eggs yeah baby makes it
better than I do now nice the sushi
chefs you know they spend years just
doing one thing the student becomes the
teacher yeah you present really well
he's ready to move on to the next thing
what's the next thing you wanna learn to
cook thank you I could teach you how to
do that
tae pour lots of pancake mix no no no no
you gotta make it from scratch flour
eggs all that stuff dang I forgot I'm
gonna have to google it all right so
this is the face that I was talking
about under our home in the garage so
you guys have seen this area before when
we've like tried to clean out our garage
but a lot of stuff accumulated again
when we were doing the Marie Kondo stuff
it's all in there actually didn't even
get rid of it it's pretty ridiculous and
then on this side we have pixels old
tank which is a snake we once had many
years ago here it's Isaac's old mattress
and then down there it's all of the
cardboard that we had when we moved in
so all of this cardboard we're trying to
get rid of but we're keeping these
because we're gonna be moving soon so we
need these these boxes
[Music]
all right this is round one that's how
much we've cleared stuffed the whole
trunk and the back seats Katie and Isaac
are gonna go do the first dump I'm gonna
stay behind and continue to tear down
those boxes we're getting stuff done
finally in the middle of the day earlier
I do two up there oh yes oh nice things
you're strong at all you do it all the
way up there we had so much fun doing
this there I almost forgot to record us
emptying out the car with the boxes is
empty again off around to
[Music]
all right so what are we doing new we
are now doing our second round we loaded
up the car
did you look back there
[Music]
we're recalling it earlier of anger
therapy anger therapy here's 30 years or
in boxes yeah
are you excited to be moving I think
yeah I actually have yeah
what is the number ones the earth
looking forward to the folks
yeah that's gonna feel different than
from living in a rental property
I guess the thing I'm excited about is
the living room
oh yeah what what's so exciting about
that it's like we can we can't watch TV
okay separate levels so now we have
cleared out our face that we have
intended for putting all the stuff that
we're trying to get rid of so this is to
get rid of everything in this space is
the go pile there's a lot of stuff in
here that needs to go
such ask that black bag 30 minutes later
we got all this in here now clearing it
out clearing it out an antique this old
my old iPod wow this is boomer okay this
was my pregnancy calendar it says right
here like my last period was in 2007 and
then my due date was January 27 2008 but
he was brought in January 12 Brooke the
other gave me this at the hospital like
congratulations you're gonna have a baby
and then I put in here like all my
doctor's appointment like the glucose
test that I had to get all the baby's
first cake July 15 2007 yeah nice this
guy right here this guy going Brett
Brett hmm I've never seen these before
look at me yeah you look like me you
look like me that's a lot of people
saying we should hang up like frames in
our new house like family photos and
you're like our wedding food yeah things
that show that we act are actually a
family here's my little deck deck oh
yeah my needle Jack Jack babies and then
I cut I cut those hair off and then
little cholo here yeah cute mmm no
that's huge
I mean at least not to my parents but um
you want to be cute to your parents who
do you want to be cute to you know I
mean I mean easily
this is me cute little red mcclain she
was a turtle this is his first Halloween
you're photogenic baby Isaac very
photogenic baby what happened what
happened I got I got prettier hi I'm
covering my stomach but I was like a
month pregnant here let's live that's
how my teeth used to be nice and crooked
[Music]
[Music]
look at my handprints from when I was in
preschool oh my gosh the paper is
falling apart oh wow must be writing my
name in preschool look at this this is
me I like my eyes yzma and then my quick
look listen I wrote when I grow up I
want to be a mother
oh really you're gonna bro me for that
it's hella cute all right we are at the
scrap yard again fired up fired alright
we are now about to take a lunch break
what are you saying about this is
broccoli in wrong it's man-made it's not
real it's not real vegetable salvation
you say it like you're so disappointed
like it's man-made
I remember broccoli is my favorite and
then I thought I was like yeah I'm
eating my vegetables but I'm so healthy
for you my life has been why we got rid
of all the cardboard and now we're left
with a whole bunch of styrofoam chaff
rear I had to dispose of it in a proper
way
yeah we are running out of sunlight
because we started so late
[Music]
dude perfect nice you nailed it
[Music]